all right well uh welcome back to the
corridor cast and uh we are here with a
very special guest
um also this is my first time kind of
introducing a podcast and if you don't
know who I am I'm Jonah I'm usually one
of the guests so it's a bit of a new uh
flavor but uh I'm really excited because
we have Mike Pesci on the couch with us
today
um who I'm legitimately a huge fan of I
love your work I love your podcast it's
time it's not enough room for my head
yeah um and I somehow convinced him to
be on the podcast and I'm super grateful
you're here so uh thank you yeah um
we're also yeah we're joined by Nick and
uh Fenner uh The Usual Suspects
um and yeah we're just really excited to
uh to get to know you a little bit and
hear about your work
um yeah go ahead should we should we
start off with how we met Mike because
that was like Super Rad so we had uh the
guys from Puget who hook us up with all
the awesome computers we have they were
coming by and I guess you are also
buddies with them we all just ended up
going out for beers together and of my
friend yeah and it was uh I don't know
man it was awesome so huge is great man
Puget has sponsored me for like six
years yeah and they are they're killing
it
um and I've seen them their company just
expand and grow
um they just sent me a new computer
this week that I'm not supposed to talk
about oh but it's pretty [ __ ] sweet
um and uh the thing I like about them is
that uh those dudes love to drink yeah
so I'm actually hanging out with them
after this so we should all go yeah
so yeah yeah get you those are the dudes
yeah go ahead I was gonna say it like
say I was a guy who just met you once at
a bar and we'd talk a little bit it's
pretty and now we're sitting down for
podcasts like hypothetically what do you
do man like what do I do what's your
story
well I pretend to direct most of the
time uh I I started
the long story of it was that when I was
younger I thought I was going to be a
comic book artist and I really wanted to
uh recreate the books that I grew up
loving
um and ultimately I got into comic books
because my grades were terrible and my
parents grounded me from television so I
didn't get to watch any TV for my whole
High School career so I was just reading
comic books all the time
um and I fell in love with the art of
telling stories and panels which I know
all you guys know
um and
then applied to art school and because a
grades suck our school was like you're
not getting in and so I was like well I
guess I'm not doing that
um and so I went to work for a music
store okay and uh really got into like
music and and introducing people to
music and I thought I was going to be a
radio DJ
so I went to school for radio DJ and I
did my first show which was like 3 A.M
on like a like a college radio station
and the uh program director came in and
he was like all right so top of the hour
every 15 minutes you play a CD that has
a green sticker on it bottom of the hour
you play every CD that has a yellow
sticker and I went what the [ __ ] am I
doing there yeah
um and I happen to be taking for credits
a film course
and in that film course I just had my
eyes blown open and it was like this is
everything I love everything all about
music everything I love about comic
books and uh
I just uh
dived into it and I've been
a director I've been freelance I haven't
worked for anybody for 20 22 years so
wait how old were you when you decided
like I want to make films like because a
lot of people like like myself and I'm
sure a lot of people like Joan I'm not
sure about you were pretty young I was
like 10 years old I was like dangerously
young you know even younger than that
like yeah not me it was late I mean I
always was the kid that had a video
camera I would do productions for book
reports like I always did that stuff but
I never really assumed that it was a job
and this is pretty this this is
pre-youtube yeah so it was a whole
generation of us that you know I didn't
believe that Indiana Jones lived in a
box in my living room but I didn't ask
about it I did really ask any questions
you know I just watched it and so when I
took that film course and we watched
Citizen Kane obviously obviously a Blade
Runner which I hadn't hadn't seen prior
to that oh wow
blew my mind open and then the film
instructor just like stopped it and went
what did you think of the Wardrobe and I
just went what it was just that moment
of like right someone gets paid to dress
these people someone gets paid to do
that and so it was kind of at that
moment where I went yeah
so maybe I'm a little slow
it was later in life I don't think that
matters at all I think actually a lot of
people like as directors and I've
struggled with this
you need that life experience to be able
to tell a story because I mean dude like
when you're in high school trying to you
know what were the movies about you that
you make in high school it's like yeah
uh the mysterious guy I met in Alleyway
but he
you're kind of just like you know it's
mostly I think technical like you learn
the technical stuff and like okay yeah I
know how to you know yeah set actors up
and set up a camera and lights but it's
like I don't feel like young people have
like
on average the best stories to tell I do
but it's important work still I talk
about this on my show all the time
it takes eight years before anybody
gives a [ __ ] about you yeah okay like
eight years from when from when you
decide from when you decide that you're
not going to do anything else so like
even if you start your like if you start
your own business yeah it takes eight
years before anybody really cares and so
in that period of time
at least when I was younger I was
incredibly frustrated I'm like I want to
make movies now yeah I want to do this
[ __ ] now and like you I I didn't have
the stories to tell so I spent the rest
of my time learning how to use this
stuff building a toolbox like I didn't
just go to school to be a director and
then like pace around my room and write
scripts all day I went and hung out with
uh boom pole guys and I went on set and
did sound and I went and learned
lighting I taught myself how to be a
cinematographer and I was a
cinematographer for years and did all
that stuff that built that toolbox and
then had the life experiences
that afterwards I went genuinely I know
what I'm supposed to go through
emotionally what the audience is
supposed to go through emotionally so
now I can rely on the tools to safely
put them in that situation again yeah do
you feel like your podcast is like now
because that's like I guess it's weird
this like idea of like you have your
business that you're after eight years
now people they give a [ __ ] yes do you
feel like your podcast says be like
being informed by that like hey I was
going and talking to like the boom
operators I was talking to everyone
because that's kind of your thing right
you have just the whole process and like
how it all comes together and I don't
know just kind of going back to what you
were saying about like
comic book writing and stuff and then
you know you did radio DJing that's kind
of all leading towards yeah you know
directing because that is like hey I got
to be on it with the sound design I got
to be on a score the storyboarding like
all of that so yeah it's uh I don't know
it's just it's so interesting I feel
like so many people have these stories
of like oh yeah I kind of like I DJ'd a
little bit and now it's like Oh I'm a
director like it's awesome
I just I love that yeah I think your
life I mean directing really come on
directing is taste making yeah really
and if you're doing it at a larger level
um you're essentially you have people
coming up to you with platters full of
things yeah and going like which do you
want and you're like all right this
makes sense and this doesn't make sense
and I wish it was that exotic but most
of the time you're strapped to the front
of a train and you're screaming and you
know someone once said I forget who it
was they're like being a director as
being a professional question answer yes
you're just yeah on set answering
questions and like yeah and then Tim
Miller we had him on the couch and he
was saying like about 20 minutes out of
every day on set you know on whatever it
was like Terminator he's talking about
was it actually directing actors arrest
was just like trying to bond with the
crew trying to answer questions trying
to you know take care of all the
logistics and just crashing against you
yeah did you Nick did you find that on
your film hope that you did because
you're still in production on it like
post-production right now we're done now
you're done but it was well since we
were so low budget yeah it was a little
bit less answering questions because
there weren't as many people to ask
questions so but yes so totally like
there's not as much like working with
actors as you would think but when you
do it's like you really can't mess it up
but are you afraid of actors no I'm
afraid of actors being afraid of me
I I say this on the show and I always
make actors laugh so come on I go when I
first started when I first started I saw
actors as this like herd of unicorns
that I would like leave Skittles on the
ground oh yeah and hopefully not scary
no honestly you know what I mean you're
just like oh it took years for me to
realize like now there's a method
there's a process and really it's a it's
a trust game and then it was when I
started to be comfortable with myself
and being able to communicate with
strangers and openly and honestly then I
found that actors gravitated
towards me so because I come from a
technical side yeah I'm sure a lot of
you guys do so you didn't have that like
vocabulary of like how do I how do I
like tell you to emote a certain way and
it's really hard because you can't just
say be happier well and but but also
you're not if you're if you're we can
get real nerdy about it if you're doing
it the right way you're not telling them
to do anything if you're doing it the
right way you're just having
conversations and you're casting
somebody because they embody
who this character is and so you're
you're asking questions you're not
actually telling them to do anything
you're like what if before you walk into
the scene you were at the DMV and you
were there for 12 hours and she didn't
give you your driver's license what
would happen here it because then you're
you're building this storm of
collaboration which I really enjoy
because if you go through the whole
process of storyboarding your movie
doing everything it when you're sitting
at your desk you're essentially
envisioning this film and if you're
living
by that Bible every step of the way is
[ __ ] boring for you and it's
disappointing because you're never
really living up to what that initial
intent and so if you open it up you're
surprised like you show up and I'm like
dude would you get that oh [ __ ] yeah and
the next thing you know like that ends
up being your favorite scene so this
might be a weird question but with 12K I
watched it last night it's Mike's
awesome short film
how how because of the films in Russian
I'm assuming yes how did you find that
process like and how were that were
those all like first like their first
language was Russian all the actors and
yes was it this might be an unfair
question but
Joan and I were both like man the acting
isn't this is really good I think
because I don't understand Russian and
for that matter you shot that in Boston
right yeah yeah so there's that element
too where like yeah why what was that
choice and and how did that inform the
way you made it
foreign
there's a longer story let me do the
paraphrased version of this so
um
we'll get into my head injury but the
head injury stimulated this idea wait it
looks like Nick it looks I'm so just
like for me and the audience yeah can
you just give us like a synopsis of what
is 12K yeah and maybe maybe touch on the
head injury
you guys let's start with a head injury
I want to hear this so I did a proof of
concept film called 12 kilometers so 12
km and it's about a Russian drill team
in the 1980s that dug the deepest hole
known to man and uh it's a true story
and they dredged up something awful now
in the actual story uh they lower
microphones down into the planet and
they supposedly hear the sounds of Hell
which I thought was kind of cheesy and
I'm like
um so what I did is I I heard about the
story years prior and I'm like it's a
cool story I don't know what I'm gonna
do with it who the [ __ ] is gonna pay me
to do this
um so I just sort of put it away and
like so many ideas like I'm sure we all
have
they just don't have their place at that
time so you write it in a notebook you
go away
um I used to run a production company
back in Boston and we were so busy for
years I think like
12 years went by music videos and time
just traveled on me and I wasn't making
movies I was just trying to keep this
business open in afloat and I was pretty
unhappy
um and I
met this girl
and we started dating and we would go
out and do a couple different dates and
she was throwing out the idea of ice
skating she's like I'd like to go ice
skating at Frog Pond down down in Boston
we should go do it
and I was like yeah
because I had never put ice skates on in
my life and so I was like all right
whatever and so they finally hit that
day where she came to me and she said
you know when we date we only do what
you want to do you've never done what I
want to do and I went I knew this day
was coming so I I said all right let's
do it and I said to myself okay what's
the worst that's going to happen I'll
twist an ankle I'll do something okay so
I go down to Frog Pond which is like
basically the equivalent of like a
Central Park
big ice skating place lots of people
very romantic I go down I'm putting I'm
putting blades on my feet it's like very
foreign to me and I'm trying to be cool
you know still East Coast you know I'm
trying to be a cool dude go in the
process of doing this and try to impress
this girl yeah
get the ice skates on she pulls me on
ice and she's pulling me around like a
toddler you know and it's just very
emasculating
yeah
it's hard to look cool as a toddler
I'm getting pulled all over the place
and so I said to her I go just give me a
sec skate away I'll figure this out and
she goes okay and so I turned next to me
this little brat like a little
five-year-old brat that's like pure
wedding around me and lands next to me
and I watch him as he just pushes off
okay and I went all right so I push off
and I literally go
all the way back
land on the back of my head so I do a
complete 180. land and the last thing I
hear is the sound of an old oak barrel
cracking and I'm out now but there's no
Oak barrels
That's my boy so I'm out cold and so the
girl tells me that everybody on the ice
hears this so like I'm out oh man and so
she skates over and it's like I don't
know if you guys ever played the old NHL
hockey where like the dude out on the
ice that's me and so
she skates over and the owners of the
ring skate over with little orange cones
and set up orange cones around me so
that people can continue to skate they
were ready
please so uh she begs they call an
ambulance I wake up
uh to flashlight in my eyes and there's
a doctor looking down on me now I at
this point I go oh [ __ ] because I got a
ton of work to do all week and I'm like
I broke my leg I did something I passed
out my doctor looks down at me and he
goes uh here's the deal
you've cracked your skull
you're bleeding internally there's a
hematoma forming on the top of your
brain applying pressure to your brain
and what we normally do is we drill into
your skull to release the pressure
because it wasn't bleeding out anywhere
but the hematoma is on the main blood
vessel of your brain so if we drill just
a skosh too deep you die you bleed out
and you die instantly and I went okay
and he goes so what we're going to do is
see if the bleeding stops we're going to
wait here and see you can't go to sleep
we're going to keep you awake call your
family and that was that was it and so
the girl was there and she I'm looking
at her and I'm like
I'm out of it and I'm like you got to
call my family so she has to call my fit
my meet most of my family for the first
time raise the family and True Story I
mean I know there was a movie made about
this later it was ripping me off like we
did this we were the original species
story yeah and so uh I ended up going I
was in intensive care for five days I
had these crazy hallucinations because
of the pressure that was on my brain and
I I was convinced that my inner voice
wasn't mine I was convinced that it was
like somebody else's and sorry where
they were they were keeping you up that
whole time yeah you weren't allowed yeah
I wasn't allowed to sleep so the first
five days well I mean like I would drift
but they would like is he awake is he
awake is he awake so it was like one of
those that sounds like torture yeah it
was crazy so you start like going in
this really weird place and there's
recordings of it I think she still has
them
uh I would tell the girl that I was with
hey I need to tell you because I was so
fascinated I'm like I need to tell you
what's going on and so she'd record me
going like this is what's happening the
Shadow's moving and all this stuff and
uh so I went to that whole process the
bleeding stopped and they said okay uh
we're going to put you in general
population wherever they send regular
people to hospital
like that yeah back into prison and so
she goes uh we'll put you there and
we'll see if your your brain absorbs the
blood and uh you need about five six
months for recovery and so I had uh
multiple concussions I had vertigo
and the whole ordeal and um
that whole period of time I was so
inspired by what I was seeing in the
hospital that when I got back I ended up
staying with my parents thank God for
like five months it was really nice
um
I was at home dealing with migraines
going I gotta write this out I could
write this yeah and uh 12 km was just
going to be the cold open okay for the
story and it was like where does this
creature that is infecting you come from
yeah it came from Russia and so I wrote
what was essentially like 10 pages of
like
meanwhile Russia boom and this is
everything that happened in Russia
uh five months later fully recovered
lucky as hell fully recovered walked out
of it and then was like at the time went
to my business partner I said I don't
care what's going on I need to make this
movie I need to make film because it was
the one thing you know there were
multiple times during that process where
I almost died like I think one day I
sneezed too hard and I thought the
bleeding started again or something
happened and so you're in that boat
going what have I not done with my life
yeah and I'm like I've never made a
[ __ ] movie dude going back to what
we're saying which is like these stories
almost find you and you need less
experience yeah a crazy life experience
near-death experience like this it's
like that that story put itself right in
in your lap essentially I was very lucky
man awesome I look at it the whole
process is being
fortunate I mean a lot of people would
look at that going like my life is
ruined and I had that was fortunate man
because
uh I found a home for that Russian story
that I always wanted to tell
and when I decided to make it as a proof
of concept
before I had my head injury I had done a
Punisher fan film okay so I did a movie
called The Dead can't be distracted
which Disney found out about and they
sent me like we're going to end your
life season desist orders so I could not
release it
um
the internet loves it and I get I get
written to like once or twice a week I'm
like can you release this and I'm like
it's never coming out it's like the punk
rock album that will never be seen or
heard
um so after doing that I had asked all
my friends to do a short and I had
brought them all in and it's like
everybody's gonna see this it's going to
be really great and they did really
really great work for it
fast forward to when I'm about to do
another one I went all right I can't
reach into that well and not do
something that doesn't get into the
theaters no matter what and so I
expanded 12 cam into being 30 minutes
long so that I can do a screening for it
I could do
a multiple screenings for it
um and yeah and and because I was My Own
Boss
I was like I'm gonna do it in Russian
whoa Okay so and so you made this when
did you film this recently no no this
was uh this was a while ago okay
and it's been myth because I haven't
released it online
free okay it's been over five years like
20. I watched it in 2017. yeah it's been
a while yeah yeah it's been a while and
correct me if I'm wrong like it was a
pretty tight shoot like you shot it in
how many days was it I think pathology
effects and everything
seven days yeah and did you shoot a red
sky
yes we did one day at Red Sky I used to
work in the in the red sky building okay
um that was like where Vegas
and and that studio is like amazing yeah
and uh yeah because I thought I was the
void was that guy's guy yeah they hated
me because I had all that black sand
there yeah
this was like a proper soundstage area
that you had access to yeah you built uh
some sets no so we did we did like the
you haven't seen the movie so it's not
enough yeah
I'm playing the dumb guy here so we we
built this void for like I don't want to
give anything away but the end of the
movie takes place in this void
um and that was in a sort of blacked out
space but everything that takes so we
had to build the Russian drilling site
we had to do everything period uh 1980s
we had this small town outside of Boston
called
I think it was Franklin okay no yeah it
was it Franklin I think it was Franklin
that we were in and uh there was this
Warehouse
that I talked the owner into letting me
have for an entire month well for free
it's like industrial building and then
we just built sets yeah and my art team
was doing uh midnight shifts for me
because they were working on
what was that movie was it surrogates
that they were working on in Boston they
were working on some big movie and then
they would come do my art stuff at night
and so it took them about a month to
build
the whole drill site and all that stuff
and
sourcing
sourcing audio equipment from the 1980s
was difficult but then I had to Source
Russian audio equipment
which by uh props people came to me and
went
this is impossible and I went all right
well how about our guys are doing this
off the radar and their government isn't
financing it so they had to go to the
black market to get American equipment
and I'll have one of the guys have a
translating dictionary there trying to
figure out how to use the American
Equipment to make your life professional
Yeah question answer yeah yeah that's
exactly it exactly the professional
question yeah yeah so like I'm assuming
you had some money to make this was all
self-funded uh I raised a bit from uh I
did a quick Kickstart or Kickstarter
Campaign which I think we raised like 20
May under 20 and then I I funded most of
the rest of it
um which I didn't mind it's like you
invest in yourself totally you know I
think if you invest in yourself other
people believe in you more so Nick with
your film did you do any crowdfunding
for that or was that all self-funded as
well do crowdfunding no we between like
the three producers we all kind of
sourced or um you know I I put some
money invested myself as well in it
my brother is a co-producer on it
um one of the co-producers you know put
in some as well so we we scrapped
together and then a couple other like
random you know producers that yeah are
attached as well just financially but
it's a good investment yeah I'd say it
is one of the things that we had talked
about when we first met and I found
really interesting because we're working
on a project together that we chat with
you a little bit about obviously you
related because it was it's an existing
property that we're doing
um and you did obviously punish her and
um I love you know there has to be
strategy in the creative things that you
make you know you don't want to just
make something because you think it's
fun
um not in this business you know if you
want to be successful and you were
talking about how you needed it to be 30
because you wanted it to be screened and
you want all this stuff where's the line
for you where you want to make the thing
that you want to make you have a moment
in your life where you say I I need to
actually commit to myself and make the
things I want to make but also balance
like well it needs to be successful for
yeah right it's a tough line dude
because
I've fallen victim to the this isn't
right because there isn't right things
and so like a lot of time goes by yeah
like uh I've you know with covid and
everything there was a period of time I
hadn't directed anything and like two
and a half years three years or
something and and of course I was doing
all sorts of other [ __ ] but you you
there's a hundred reasons why you can't
make something you should make something
so it's a delicate line there I think
the conversation that we were having was
do something that you can then sell
because there I think what I've
understood coming out here and and going
through the process of having films and
development and having property that I
own IP that I own yeah they just flock
to you and I had done that Punisher
piece and got some attention off the
fact that I wasn't allowed to release it
and I think I got more attention
yeah the original Batgirl
we want to see this yeah dude 100 and
then all the theories start going like
why did they care dude I could thank my
lawyer for that man oh yeah oh yeah
because I already had lawyers well well
dude because you you know the [ __ ]
Mouse shows up and yeah and and yeah you
know and my lawyer said it smart to me
he or he was really smart about it he
was like
I'm like I don't have anything so what
difference does it make he goes it's not
now
it's when you're it's when you do
something yeah the mouse comes out yes
yeah and do something about a hole in
the corner yeah it turns out Disney was
the Russian drilling team the whole time
yeah
it's everywhere no Disney's great
Disney's really good
um I love Disney yeah yeah of course
yeah thank you Mickey Mouse for your
contributions of course that's such a
good Mouse I'm such a favorite man I'm
such a tiny blip on their carpet
somewhere uh but uh the stuff that I
ultimately learned from that was that
doing my own stuff made me so much more
valuable and it was a risk I took
working with someone else's IP because
at the time there was a bunch of other
pieces that had come out I'm like oh
there's gonna be a lot of attention but
if you look at those other directors
that do those other pieces it's not like
I I think it was only one piece maybe it
was the Mortal Kombat piece or something
where the actual director got hired I
forget which one it was but they don't
come and hire you they go oh there's
interest in this okay great we'll do
this and then you're just like oh okay
that's really interesting like uh Tim
Miller spoke about that a little bit
with that cool yeah he was like you know
like if I hadn't made that previz they
would not have you know even though I
was attached from the beginning almost
they wouldn't have had him be the
director yeah like they would have just
gone with whoever was the hottest first
directing gig yeah it's huge but like
she did it he made it I mean he had an
animation studio and they did a killer
job and it hyped everyone up but because
of that you know they were like okay
this guy you know he can do it and he
wants to do it so I'm sure the support
of like uh Ryan Reynolds Reynolds
probably helped yeah you know and having
him in it probably helps a lot but yeah
dude I mean
it's a [ __ ] gamble like it's our
business is so
it's so difficult because there's no
rules there's no formula and then most
of the time when you go in you're
talking to the money people and they're
just like so flighty dude it is crazy
and they reduce everything to the dollar
sign right like which yeah at the end of
the day if you're catering to that idea
though then I think that's the strategy
that you can take which is back to what
you said like what's your goal creative
goal you know yeah and I don't mind the
dollar like I get the dollar thing and
if that's your thing then I'm like dude
I'm here to make you money like that's
fine
the flyiness of like the attention span
of people that are just like gravitating
towards the easiest thing like and
they're just like oh is this hereditary
oh is this this oh am I going to make
money selling like you know tokens
online for this like they they're so all
over the place and they're really not
investing in
us yeah they're not investing in the
storytellers and if you've directed
anything like you guys have you know
that a lot of what we find is finding it
like we have a great idea but we have to
find it it's like you actually have to
start doing it like like it has to kind
of inform itself and right
it's risky like how do you about how do
you balance all that money on that you
don't because like you look at all these
big Studio reshoots they do where these
top tier directors and I mean that girl
the whole thing was scrap because yeah
it's like they didn't balance it they
didn't like and they had these such high
expectations of like you're gonna churn
out these cookie cutter movies and it's
not a factory dude it's really as much
as they want to make it a factory and
you can see the stuff that is processed
the way a factory would process it and
you're kind of like like what is this
[ __ ] yeah yeah Mickey Mouse
we love Disney
this isn't it
right Mouse energy
um just with your movie like what's uh
like what is your plan for getting it
out there because like with 12K Mike
like you're not really able to see that
online right like yeah I'm kind of a
dick about it yeah the only way you can
see the movie is if you write to me on
Instagram and tell me your three
favorite horror movies if I agree with
you then I'll send you so there are
three correct horror movies no there's
not three corrects
it's not like some code for some like
species
no no no you just you know what it is is
that I find that if you dump things out
into the ocean that is the internet then
people are passively watching stuff and
then really not invested in it but if
there is front loaded investment then
they're like I've earned this yeah and
most people that watch it they don't
have to like it but they at least
want to talk to me about it afterwards
so I'm getting like really good
engagement and then it's also building I
learned that from The Punisher piece
it's also building a lot of hype around
it because not everybody can see the
[ __ ] it's shoes it's sneaker drops
exactly so Nick his ears like is it a
YouTube thing is it a like no DM you on
Instagram thing like
well and this is not a slight I hope it
won't be a DMV on Instagram thing I hope
people can stream it sometime eventually
but I mean to what you said our goal
going into it was
well covet happened and it was like
we're kind of bored and
um wanted to just make a movie this is
me uh Chris Marone and Kika magalesh who
are my partners on the movie Chris wrote
the screenplay she had the story and
they both acted in it so we made a
perfect Trio hell yeah well produced it
I directed I had experience with that
they had experience acting obviously so
yeah it it worked out and we're like
let's just do it is it a feature or is
it a feature okay so you're in a whole
different boat that's great dude and
Nick did you feel like like was covid
your ice skating incident you're like
dude
it was definitely a weird way to make my
first feature film and yes and Kika as
well but it kind of like it almost
forced you into it right because it was
that's sitting around of like God I just
gotta do something yeah man and it had
always been a goal it was like I really
want to make this and like I didn't know
how to make a project that big and it
was just like let's just we have the
script this is a story where we all feel
pretty strongly about it's a story about
a woman who's like kidnapped in human
trafficking
yes it's basically a horror you know but
a lot of it's like you know on the road
and stuff so locations are not the
hardest
um people were bored during covid
they're like we're not getting any work
can I help and we're like heck yes you
can come on out wear a mask please
um locations were cheap like all the
bars were shut down you know people
wanted to make a buck where they could
yeah [ __ ] yeah so things logistically
worked out I had to direct actors with a
mask on yeah
got really good at eyebrows yeah but
um you're doing really good work yeah
it's like dead but things just came
together and and we shot it and probably
spent another 5K on it in post which
isn't that bad actually but it's been
really just like
pushing a train slowly down the tracks
and we're finally to the point where we
like last week literally we started
sending it out to everyone we've been
waiting we had like a whole list of like
everyone's like waiting to see the movie
and we're like cool email email so we'll
see what happens but you had to slowly
work through that process of saying yes
and no taste making yeah dude well dude
also congratulations thank you man yeah
thank you that's a huge congrats yeah
I'm sorry again yet yeah that's awesome
dude you're in like that shock
afterwards honestly I'm kind of numb
because the last two years it's been
like every I go home every night from
this job and I do that yeah so it's been
a lot on everyone's uh on everyone's
plate but I hope we can get it sold just
the fact that you shot it just the fact
that you did it the hurdles that I think
most people don't understand the hurdles
that it takes for you to get to that
point and you feel different after doing
that right I feel like I'm ready to make
my first feature now yeah yeah like
honestly like I felt I feel like I went
to film school again in the last two
years yeah
um and now now I'm not scared of it
anymore though you know like
um yeah dude when we first when we said
we're gonna make this and I transferred
the money into the the production
company bank account I'm like okay we're
making this I'd like a two-week panic
attack almost yeah so I was like oh
this is gonna be like three months of
shooting weekends so I'm not gonna have
a day off for three months I'm not gonna
have a Christmas break because we're
gonna shoot 10 days straight during my
Christmas break like no weekends I'm
like just I I was with ran on a trip and
like I didn't get like sleep for two
days and I was like freaking out like I
looked back and I was like I was so
scared of that but then the first day we
get on set and everyone you see the crew
there and everyone's just so stoked and
like
that the next that night I slept so well
and did you feel like that first day on
set was like oh this is what the last
eight years ten years however many years
has been leading up to because you're
like oh I'm almost I can do this I felt
so real dude yeah it felt very serious
really cool um like yeah it was and it
just was like a Non-Stop blur from there
dude I'm jealous I'm jealous of you
right now just because it's been a while
since I've been on that situation and
when you feel that when you're on set
and you start to see things come
together it's like the ultimate high
like this is endorphin rush of
collaboration that you feel totally dude
and yeah it's also scary because you're
like okay this is it this is what it
looks like yeah I've been imagining this
let's make it work yeah sometimes you do
and a lot of times you don't and that's
that's where the learning comes in
though I have dude
that's rad man I have such a long list
of like everything I would do next time
and I will do next time yeah
um but like it makes it it makes it very
interesting to look back on a film that
you shot two years ago and say like yeah
I want to put this out there because you
don't really want to wow yeah
and you're gonna let it live exactly and
that's what we're gonna do and hopefully
you know hopefully we will distribute it
somehow and you know people will be able
to stream it I just want to do are you
gonna do a screening we are going to do
screening that's weird that's the [ __ ]
not it dude like when you get in the
room with people that is like the
purpose I know so many directors I don't
know if you guys are you know so many
directors that are afraid to be in the
room when they screen stuff oh no that's
the best part it's the best [ __ ] part
man you learn so much instantly yeah
okay yeah yeah and people don't even
have to sing I'm terrified dude I'm like
I'm terrified yeah
no it's gonna be awesome man I like
personally like coming from and because
I started editing that was like my way
into this industry like my favorite part
is watching it with people because yeah
I'm not watching the screen I'm watching
them you know yeah I'm like what's
hitting what isn't hitting and like
after so much work to be able to you
have an emotional impact on an audience
you know it the funny part about what we
do is that the most exciting part for us
is doing it but the most exciting part
for everyone else is watching it and
there's this weird like it's a delayed
moment yeah and so you're feeling
relieved and that it's over but
everyone's just excited to watch it no
one's been there with you right exactly
your process has ended in everyone
else's process is beginning so you get
to relive it again with everyone else
yeah thanks for reminding me of that
because
I'm sure you guys can relate though like
once you live with a video for a while
you've been through everything and
you've you know you know everything
wrong with it and you know all the
solves that you've done and you forget
that people are literally going to be
seeing these images for the first time
ever yeah
people laugh at a joke he wrote two
years ago and you're like it's funny
yeah
it's funny so yeah that's very important
to remember it's like you you notice all
the flaws because you've been living
with them and you're just like oh I hate
how this looks I hate how this sounds
and then but someone sees like oh man I
loved like I loved everything and you're
like [ __ ] yeah but the older you get I
think the more time you do it the flaws
just become part of like yeah I I just I
equate it to cooking all the time right
because I that's what I would do in the
interim I would make meals during covid
because it was like making mini movies
yeah and I can like sort of have that
experience yeah and the sensory sort of
experience but you know sometimes you
don't play things right sometimes you've
got like
steaks overcooked or like the rice is a
little rubbery but the whole experience
is a really great one and then you start
to Treasure
you know the meal not just the food that
you're serving dude you know completely
man it's yeah I
much different person than I was two
years ago based on that project and I
treasure
really the process like
it's just again like I said it was film
school again like you know last week we
did a podcast all about film school and
like
you could just go make a movie and you'd
probably learn as much that's one of the
reasons every time I I love what we do
here too um because
working for three months in the future
and then a year and then it's snowballs
like what we do is we make something
every single week and so
you're able to work through so many
mental blocks about your creative
process when you have that timer and
it's great because if you do make
something every single week or you know
whatever that is for you and then you do
have the three months you are so
grateful right and you get to really all
the small lessons build up to the big
lesson
um and and then that project is better
for it I I'm a huge fan of of making
just the worst version of everything
first because you can't be precious you
know because every no one's first idea I
think is ever the best version of it and
like you you kind of have to put it out
there see the response and then be
humble enough to recognize like where
you're wrong you know at a certain point
the thing that you make it really isn't
yours anymore that's the way I feel you
know once you've made it a little bit
you show it to people around you and you
say like how does this make you feel and
if it doesn't make them feel the way
that you thought
it's not your fault but it is your
responsibility you know to guide that
thing that's the way I see it you know
spoken like a true editor
responsibility I mean dude it all comes
down to the editor man like yeah I think
everything I mean part of being a
filmmaker and even a director is like
knowing the edit yeah for sure you know
I need to I need to hear your top three
horror movies though I'm sorry were you
thinking about ever since you said it
you're gonna have to send those links
out to everyone
yeah
I do have a question with you guys like
both of your first kind of you're short
12K and then your film they're in the
horror genre too right so I mean not
maybe classical horror but it is a
horrifying story it is does instill fear
and like the short drone and I are
working on it has those elements of
horror as well what was it about like
the genre of having that horror that
fear that was like hey yeah this is my
first step into doing this like I've
always said there are two different
genres that I would do I would either
well three but the two ones that I would
start with would either be horror or
romantic comedy because they both get
the same level of audience reaction to
the to the trickery that you're putting
on screen there's something so great
about it on both ends and I think when
you're dealing with horror the audience
respects technical Savvy they respect uh
you know do-it-yourself techniques they
uh oftentimes celebrate a heavy hand
with the techniques that you're doing so
you can really get away with a lot
especially if you're like you know
trashing around yeah you're kind of
having fun with it but then there's a
refinement with horror that's really
fascinating and it's a timing thing like
I also was an editor so there there's
this sense of like building tension and
the most of my stuff is very suspense
driven so it's the rhythm of tension the
rhythm of of speech patterns the rhythm
of communication so I find that stuff
really interesting because it's less
about
dialogue heavy scripts that are very
sort of like narrative based it's more
about like hey here's this theme or this
idea how can I use all these magicians
tricks to like make you think that
you're getting stabbed in the face that
that makes me think like watching your
pieces and I'm sorry the audience who
can't see this but what I can say is
that every time we or the times that we
watch them when we watch them a couple
times I was I said I love the editing I
would just keep saying that how good
editing is phenomenal I love what he did
there and with that my question is how
much is how how much of the is that
boarded because you're doing these
moments of like amazing texture work
with sound design and these awesome you
know like the door and and uh who's
there you know these like sequences that
you build it to me it almost feels
impossible to board those because it
feels like you're building this Rhythm
that works so perfectly with the music
yeah what's your process finding that
um I sure I wish I had them I can show
you the storyboards for 12km they're
pretty on point
um what I see boards boards do a couple
things for me
um boards helped me block so like it's
my initial blocking
I remember once I was doing because I
did a lot of commercials back in in
Boston I remember I was doing a
commercial and I showed young young guy
doing a commercial showed up on set and
the the actor goes how do you want me to
pick this backpack up and I went oh [ __ ]
like I hadn't thought about like what
that was uh and so with boarding I found
myself when I was boarding out 12 cam I
would in my driveway back in Watertown I
would tape out what I thought the rooms
would be outside in the driveway and I'd
go walk him and I'd just be like okay
what if the guy comes here what is this
yes and sort of did that and then I was
like okay and then I would board it and
then the cinematographer side of me was
like okay here's what I think the colors
should be here's what I think the
lensing should be for this that's really
interesting and then when you start to
board things I used to hand draw them
but now I do everything digitally which
is like super fast I can then start
editing them so with the boards
themselves literally editing with the
boards sometimes it's just the way I
arrange them on the paper okay or
sometimes it's just in my mind where I
go cut from here Cut From Here Cut From
Here cut from here and I know that it's
not going to be the edit so I know that
I'm not just shooting like I only need
five frames here I'll shoot until I get
something really great but I have
pre-edited with the boards
so by the time you see like if you saw a
side-by-side kids comparison of the
boards for 12 Cam and the images they're
pretty damn on point I think still
pissed about it I only I only missed
like four shots on my board list okay
and we were doing 35 setups a day with
Dolly Steadicam my team was like
a point hustling dude 135 setups 35
setups a day uh we were on point Nick
with your film was there was there much
of that board process or was it more run
and gone was it like man uh the first
week there was yeah totally uh I had
shot lists I had boards and then then it
started and it was just like I had to
kind of go on Instinct yeah yeah and
like dude like it was like a 19 day
shoot and you know as you know low
budget stuff dude I know it's just you
literally go and you just try to get
everything and make it work so some
scenes I did have boarded like a
specific stuff on the study or whatever
like we we had that worked out but you
know it would just be I would trust that
me and the cinematographer could be on
the same page yeah which we were and it
worked out
um you know a lot of it's handheld a lot
of it's on you know dollies or like
sorry um gimbal stuff so yeah but in a
lot of it's Car mounts too a lot of
interior car stuff which is the weather
that's a whole timer yeah
um but it yeah I think one thing one big
lesson that I will apply to my next film
is more of that
um you know not writing off that process
um not that like I thought this is a
waste of time or anything it's just like
I think shooting coverage is really
detrimental a lot of the times yes I
think to the whole process yes um and I
really want to strive to not shoot
coverage anymore coverage sucks dude let
me just say it coverage coverage effin
sucks it gives you so many options like
at the same time there's no vision yeah
it's like paralysis by choice yeah yeah
exactly and you get into the edit and
you're like I can do anything infinite
yeah so what do I do I get mad it's like
oh my God this is going to look like an
episode of Law and Order you know what I
mean like what do we do here oh handheld
shaky over the shoulder back and forth
right it's like it doesn't mean anything
like this is what a lot of the young
filmmakers that listen to my show a lot
of the young filmmakers that listen to
this show need to understand there's a
language a visual language of Cinema
there's over a hundred years of meaning
behind using a 50 millimeter lens
there's when an audience looks at
something on screen instinctually
they're going to feel a certain way use
that language and that's in the prep and
every director that I've ever talked to
on the show
prep your job is prep and casting prep
and casting and so if you if you prep it
and you come up with the language when I
do boards for my movies I bring them I
put them on set they're up there and I
turn to everybody and go these are here
in case we're hungover tomorrow and we
all just need a plan so we're going to
come and just do these like if we're
having a bad day but I've scheduled it
in such a way where we can [ __ ] around
and we can play
and I've got a really good example of
this
on who's there there's a sequence
um
I ended up casting uh Maggie
um and the young girl in that and she
changed everything
she came in and she
was riveting and
almost detrimentally changed everything
because she was so good
that it [ __ ] with my other casting and
I casted her later in the game and so
um my other actors I'm not going to be
specific but some of my other actors had
to pick up their [ __ ] and they were very
nervous about it and it was a very hard
lesson for me to sort of how to process
that but anyway there's a sequence
upstairs where Maggie is behind a chair
and she's there and she's sort of hidden
behind this chair and it wasn't a sh it
wasn't a shot I had storyboarded oh wow
um and my production designer and I sort
of walked in this room and I looked
around and I said I don't like what I
have planned and he's like and he was
great dude Larry Sampson I don't know if
you've ever met him I don't think so
awesome guy back in Boston and Larry and
I walked around and he was like dude
what if she comes behind the chair and
he put himself down Behind the Chair and
he was like behind these little prison
bars and I went [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah so
we went and we shot that sequence and we
shot her looking amazing and then I had
to do coverage now I had to do coverage
on an actress who was very talented but
I felt bad for her in this moment
because Maggie was stealing all this
just sucking all the energy in the room
and so I just did this throwaway shot
where I had to do coverage of her and
that doorway and she's responding to
what Maggie sang which is essentially
your son was taken was kidnapped and the
way the actress
just listened and what she did it was
the best performance she did in the
whole piece
we called cut and I immediately realized
that
the whole rest of the afternoon that I
had bought it out was wrong
so from what she did there everything I
had planned was the wrong energy the
wrong Vibe too heavy-handed and I turned
to the entire crew and my assistant
director I said can we just take a break
take a break for 15 minutes I brought my
uh cinematographer and assistant
director over and I said
this isn't right I gotta I gotta we
gotta work this out real quick and so we
just walked down this hallway and walked
to the sequence like what are the camera
floats here and does this and my
cinematographer was like well yeah we do
that my assistant director was like on
this will happen and so we just
completely threw the boards up
redesigned that whole back end of the
sequence and it's beautifully stimulated
by the performance of the actress and I
think that's important to remember Prep
Prep Prep
learn the language for what it is that
you're making but then have the
wherewithal as the Director who AKA
you're the audience at that point so
like when you're watching it you go I
want to see what this goes and don't be
so stubborn with your prep where you're
like yeah but I I was really excited
about using the Steadicam yeah gear
related I'm just excited to get the
flares off the sweet anamorphic totally
no no no no no follow the emotion follow
the
the inspiration yeah yeah that's a good
advice man yeah just for context for the
audience uh who's there is that
available to watch on the site or is
that uh now
well look I'll be I'll be clear too both
these movies are proof of concept films
and so I don't need to release them like
I've already got them into the
production companies and the places that
are in development so it really behooves
me not to release them yet because then
the features will be that much more
stimulating and that much more
interesting I didn't need to go that
route of getting their attention by
putting it online would they be things
that you say like 12K or who's there
does become a feature yes would they be
something that you'd be willing to put
out after the fact because that that to
me like being able to go back with
District 9 and watch Neil blomkamp's
original short film he did as a like
film student I'm like
holy [ __ ] like that stuff is inspiring
to be able to see like hey this awesome
feature film 12K this is what it was and
it's just cool to be like yes hey if you
get some of your buddies together you
like make this film together and it's
just a short film or something
this is what it can become like I think
that stuff is just incredible like yes
no totally I will totally do that I've
I've screened it to a few audiences and
I've had a few things and if there are
any film festivals watching if you guys
want to take the movie in and we'll make
a big deal over it we can do that but
um yeah I agree with you I think at one
point I had plans
of destroying just the short I've had a
couple of offers for distro just for the
short
um
but at this point it's just like
I enjoy what I have going on with the
podcast now in the in the connection
that I have with the audience and the
general interest that people have with
it more than I would just you know dump
it on YouTube it's really interesting
man it's like that strategy
um it's kind of time tested like make a
short pitch it get the feature made
do you think at this point you still
want or those features that you're still
hyped about telling those stories yeah
it's weird because what ends up
happening is you partner up with
production companies and we can do a
whole podcast on this I'd love to dude
we partner up with production companies
and
everything that you've written if you've
written a script if you've written any
of that stuff is all going to get thrown
out it's all going to become something
new and and when you're collaborating
with producers they want to have
obviously investment in it yeah and
emotional investment and oftentimes
those people are bringing really great
ideas like uh 12 cam ended up
um Catching Fire as a short because I
had a friend of mine write an article on
it
uh what what website was it for
I can't remember the website but she
wrote an article on it and she said this
is a movie that no one can see and this
is the type of movie that Hollywood
should be making
and it was right around the time when
um Samberg did lights out
so good that's short yes and so
samberg's management found me
and so it was part of their their
strategy at that period of Time find
someone that's making a proof of concept
short get that proof of concept short
made
um and so because of that short I got
representation from them I got
representation from UTA and then
um got to go pitch toe like nice dude
like Michael Bay's people Sam Ramey's
people and you were pitching that idea
where did you have a whole kind of like
pocket full of different things okay so
we had 12. I had 12 cam finished and
what had happened was is I met uh who is
now my screenplay writer will Simmons
awesome dude
um he knew my cinematographer
it's so funny how you make decisions you
know how we make decisions
I decided because I had used to I shot
all of my other stuff as a shooter and I
when I made the decision to make a movie
in a language that I don't speak
I was like I can't pay attention yeah I
can't tell someone where to put a 6K and
also you know what I mean like so I I
had was
courting my buddy David Cruda he was a
cinematographer online and I really
respected his stuff and my belief is
that if you're going to collaborate with
someone they need to know more than you
do
and so
he was able to take my boards
and crudify them he's gonna like that I
said that that's trademark and and
basically put his crew dog
the techniques on them and make them
come to life even further
so since I made that call which was an
ego check because I before that I was
like oh I can do all this [ __ ] I can
shoot this I can do all this I said no
no I'm gonna we're gonna get this guy to
come in we collaborated together because
I did that then I met will who made a
short with him years prior and will had
called him for something
and uh Cruda was like can I show you
this new thing
so we sent over I wasn't even done
cutting it he sent over a rough and then
will called me and he goes dude
and he's a great he's a blacklist uh
winning screenplay writer like he's
crushing I can't say all the movies that
he's doing right now but he's crushing
um and he just said to me like what's
the feature and I said well I wrote a
script but I'm not really a screenplay
writer I do it out of necessity when I
wrote a script that's good he goes can I
do a pass
I was like who's this [ __ ] guy and
then he'd sent me his uh Blacklist
script and I went oh this dude's better
than I am uh and so I said yeah I'd make
it two pass and because he got involved
he was wrapped and so he's like I know
people at Platinum Dunes which is
Michael Bay's company
when you're done with the short let's
see if we can set up a meeting
and the funny thing was is that right
around that time I got an email from the
management company that was samberg's
company and I get this email
and they're like we read about your
short uh do you have any plans of coming
to LA and I was like yeah we're gonna go
pitch the fighting dunes and I go come
into our offices first and whenever you
read an email from a manager I just
picture like a dude in a polyester suit
in a closet yeah yeah you know what I
mean I was just like come on back kid
you know you're just like and I had no
expectations and and so we came out here
to LA and uh we went to this guy's
offices and I was expecting it to be you
know behind a laundromat
and it was like on uh Sunset and it was
in like Leonardo DiCaprio's building and
I just walked in there and I just
realized I was like holy [ __ ] like I am
out of my element like a dude from
Boston like trying to do this
and we went in and pitched
to them first and they were like we love
it we want to rep and we'll set up
meetings stay out here for 10 days
and we'll send you out and we
hit every spot and on the last day they
called and they go we're gonna go to
scot-free and in my head it's like it's
really Scott
alien like a whole ordeal and I said uh
uh I don't care if they like it or not I
have to work with these guys yeah and so
we went in and I told them my head
injury story we didn't even talk about
the movie really uh we talked about the
head injury story and we connected and
bonded on that one of The Producers
almost died similarly and uh he was like
okay
and then we I went I went home and I was
like I don't know what that means and
then we had another phone call and he
called and he was like ask me a couple
questions and he goes okay
and then we hung up the phone and I was
like what the [ __ ] does that mean yeah
so are we doing it are we not doing it
and then do it okay yeah and then they
they came on board wow and so they've
been so 12 cameras in development with
them right that's man wow it's been
there for a while but yeah I mean that's
still pretty so is this something that
you think will get made or is it this
something that they've just like
optioned and been like Hey we're gonna
sit on this well here's the I can give
you all sorts of insight uh here's the
other thing since I am technically a
first-time director meaning that my 20
years of directing doesn't really count
uh there's a price point that I have to
hit
for the first feature okay meaning like
maximum maximum budget and so say what
that is or is it no I mean typically
you're they're not going to hand you
more than 5 million uh if you're a
first-time feature director unless
there's some but but dude you go oh five
million but like uh once you're working
in that Hollywood System
I remember we were budgeting out the
feature version of this and uh I was
talking to really nice line producer and
she called me on the phone and she was
like
so do you want to build a set on a
Gimbal and I was like what like it came
out of nowhere I'm not making sure I was
like what and she goes like a gimbal I'm
like you you mean like a platform like
an automated platform that'll shake the
whole set and she goes yeah and I go no
why would you why would we do that and
she goes well it's written in the script
that there are earthquakes and stuff I
go yeah I'll have someone standing
behind shelves shaking them and someone
dripping sand over the lens and I'll
shake the lens and then there's an
earthquake and she goes oh and I go yeah
you ever seen Star Trek
she's like yeah Mike having gone through
this process now of going through the
pitch meetings and stuff yeah what would
be like if you were able to just give
some advice to the audience or to
someone like Nick who you're about to
kind of you're kind of going through
this process now like what would be your
biggest piece of advice like in general
yeah just for going through that whole
pitch process
um
interesting I guess like one thing I
could maybe add to that is there maybe
one particular piece of like Insight
that maybe from your first pitch to The
Last pitch in those 10 days that you
picked up or like yeah because it's a
crash course yeah exactly like what's
because I mean I've never done that many
pitches like I've done a couple you know
you just hear know a lot I would say I
would say two a couple things one
appreciate it okay
because it's weird
it is like you're you're going on like
you're going on like these speed dates
right
and so if if you're lucky they've seen
it right most of the time they've seen
it my guys are pretty good of sending
out the email going like close the
blinds and watch this so I walk in a
room and people would be surprised that
I wasn't Russian first off okay and then
second I need to go through the thing so
the process is weird and you meet like
the randomness
stereotypes of Hollywood that you've
ever like the coked up crazy man or like
someone else that's like like you meet
all like these wacky people along the
way so that's kind of fun and in the
beginning I was really nervous and every
pitch was like this is it yeah I'm going
in here today this is the rest of my
life this is what I'm pitching for this
is my dream this is my career and then
you just start to understand that like
now this this could take like five years
yeah
so as you just sort of let out that
stress
because you I see you like you do like
you can do it man you know it's been two
years it'll take me maybe next year I'll
come back
because if you let it out and you just
understand like you've already done it
yeah you've accomplished it you've made
the movie you've spent the time you've
learned the lessons if at its worst all
you do is walk away with the lessons
that you've learned it is worth that
money that you spent someone asked me
because it's been so long to get this
movie made they go do you think you
wasted your money on uh 12 Cam that
amount of cash you spent I went if
someone said to you you can write a
check for a specific amount in
guaranteed sit in Ridley Scott's office
and have him say that he likes your
movie would you write that check
yeah oh yeah all day and so that's what
you need to understand is like as you go
through this process I'm sure your
movie's awesome I can't wait to see it
thanks man as you go through this
process you're gonna meet some [ __ ]
wild people and some interesting folks
yeah man and that's the
that's what this is that's what all this
is yeah man it's it's crazy to hear your
take on that because
there's been so many points where it's
like everything rests on this one moment
you know and you have to treat it like
that but you also have to understand
like it totally doesn't it doesn't it
totally doesn't like if everyone
yeah the world doesn't revolve around
you know your movie and you as a person
and a filmmaker
but like it's like you hear about these
big directors and it takes them like
five years to get a movie developed they
have like A-list cast of like attached
yeah which is a huge part of it and like
it makes you really just realize like
there's so many factors here going in to
make that much money going behind a
project well to do that and then you hit
a point like there was a point when my
I could share this stuff there was a
point when my guys were like
and by guys I mean my representation was
like
uh
I think this movie's dead you know
there's there's points where they go
like this isn't gonna happen
and at the same at the same at the
counteractive there's like I've had my
guys call me on the phone I've had a
phone call they're gonna hate me for
saying this [ __ ] I've had a phone call
where all of a sudden there's Applause
and everybody's like clapping on the
phone and I'm like what's going on and
they're like we've done it we did it you
did it you had such a great meeting it's
successful it's going to happen and I'm
just like what it's gonna I'm like when
the paperwork yeah let me know
so like you just and I've had these
calls over the course of a day where
you get called and it's like so-and-so
is interested and you're like oh [ __ ]
it's like get your [ __ ] together and
that you hustle and you put together
boards you put together treatments and
you're just gonna do all this and you
sell it and you and you go into a pitch
and you sit there in a pitch and you're
nervous because you're like [ __ ]
everything's coming to this moment you
pitch real hard and then you don't get a
call
or they call you and they go they love
it and you go wow is this gonna happen
and then you talk for like
you like verbally masturbate each other
talking on the phone about like oh it's
so great you did such a good job and
then you get off that call and then
nothing [ __ ] happens and it's like
two or three weeks and nothing has
happened so at the end of it you just go
why am I getting so psyched out yeah
because I was
dude I I got a psychiatrist because of
this business really yeah just yeah
getting yourself I'm not ashamed to say
that these days like yeah dude Justice
dealing with the industry like I had to
get help because they sort of hits a
point where you go like this is so
inhuman the way that this industry works
the way that this industry treats us as
creatives what it puts us through yeah
um
it sucks and and so I would say the best
advice I can give you is like enjoy it
enjoy the [ __ ] ride I love that this
may not be your movie
this may not be the one that catches
fire but you may go take a meeting do a
general meeting somewhere meet a
producer who goes I like this guy you're
a cool dude I like your mustache
and so that friendship Garners he may
say to you like look I like your movie
man but there's no way I can [ __ ]
sell that what else you got yeah yeah
it's interesting well I was gonna ask
you actually like do you think it's more
about you selling yourself are you
selling the movie yourself yourself okay
dude I go into General meetings and I
will talk about barbecue for 40 minutes
and do those those meetings feel better
yes than the ones where you're just
talking about the project yes because at
the end of the day if they're taking you
in for a meeting
most of the time they've seen your work
already and the thing that's great
there's two points here
making a proof of concept is essential
as a director because you're
establishing tone yeah
you can establish tone on paper
on paper everybody reads things
differently everybody thinks that
they're a filmmaker everybody paints
pictures their own way
proof of Concepts you're establishing
tone so if you have that then they know
your tone they know what it is that you
do so when they call you in the room
what they're finding out is how do you
handle stress how do you handle
Communications do I want to be stuck
with this [ __ ] uh for years 16 hours
a day doing stuff and so I find that the
thing to do is to go in there and I do
the same thing or I look at this person
and go do I want to be stuck with this
person which Hollywood archetypes
do you feel like um
because you you came out here uh you did
those pitches and it seems like you
stuck out here
um and with the stress of pitching what
you're talking about has the podcast
helped you work through some of that
just breaking down those doors and just
meeting people and talking about
barbecue I know you say you talk about
barbecue and I've listened to it you
know and you're able to work through
that like what does what does in love
with the process mean to you as the
person who's doing it not the person
who's listening right I selfishly do it
yeah I really do I like come on man like
I don't get paid I don't get paid a ton
of money like we now have sponsors and
I'm able to keep things afloat which is
really great
um but I I do it selfishly I do it
because this right here I'm learning
something again listening to your
stories I'm learning something about
myself just telling my stories and so at
its core level being able to communicate
with strangers and Friends uh and build
relationships with people just upon the
passion that we we [ __ ] all have yeah
I feel so I did a podcast before we came
here today
yeah I feel so good about it yeah you
know and so
um that's really great it's been good uh
to make connections with people in the
business we talked about this before
um so like if I want to meet like I I
know the production designer for
Ghostbusters and Ford versus Ferrari and
him and I got along really well on a
podcast
um there's a bunch of actors that I've
talked to that I want to work with uh I
really love Bill heck he's an awesome
dude shout out bill
um and
um
I also have had producers on the show
and other people and then we also have
barbecue people on the show we have
firefighters yeah there's no rules
what we're doing is we're telling
stories about life and what you were
saying earlier if you don't have the
experiences and you don't spend time
living then who the [ __ ] are you to tell
stories about life yeah
and so I think that the podcast really
does a bit of all that and then it
connects me to my fan base and connects
me to my audience yeah my audience gets
special things
whether it's you know gear or access to
see the movies and um I love it man it's
it's
been my therapy that's good it's really
cool man I I feel like having something
like that and like for for me it's like
being able to make videos for corridor
and yeah have an audience that we're
entertaining and teaching stuff to
that like I was asking myself because
like I always wanted to be a feature
filmmaker right yes many people do yeah
um lots of us you know who are now
working in YouTube and New Media
that was the dream and still is but it's
like you kind of you kind of like ask
yourself
is what you know we're doing here at
Corridor and what you're doing on
podcast like even though it's on like
you know a smaller scale you're not
getting in front of like billions of
people in the theater
like you still get to like really be
there for people and entertain them and
like teach them and Inspire them dude
and that like really it's really like
laid off the pressure for me and like
feeling like
I'm late to being the future film
director that I wanted to be because I
can still contribute and like have that
like I mean validation one of like hey
I'm making something that's valuable to
people and that they want to watch
um but also like what is why did I want
to be a feature film director so that's
funny dude you know so I could make
things that people watched yeah so it's
funny dude I had the same I had the same
[ __ ] thoughts man and and I was
talking to my therapist about it there
hits this point because one of my I'm 44
now 43 44. so
um I was like Ridley Scott made a
[ __ ] his first feature film at 40
years old so I can do this at 40. and
then what happened [ __ ] covid right
and I was online I didn't have that I
was online for everything everything was
lined up everything's ready to rock
[ __ ] covet right so kova comes in and
I was beating myself up emotionally
about this consistently and I was
talking to therapist she's like what is
this time that you're doing
and I was like well if I don't make a
movie
that I'm not a director and if I'm not
directing that I'm not a director and
she's like yeah but you've been
directing for 20 years and I go yeah but
I'm not directing right now so that
means I'm not a director she goes you're
a director dude and you've been a
director for 20 years and I went okay
and she goes what's this number that you
put on time and I go
I don't know I it just makes sense I
need to have some sort of number for it
and she goes how old is Clint Eastwood
and granted he comes from a different
place than I do but he's still making
flicks yeah and I consistently say that
if I go when I go
when I drop finally I'm going to Keel
over a craft services
not a bad place to be yeah yeah like
it's one too many of the Starbucks
sandwiches you know I just got into the
heart and you just got it it was a
Starbucks sandwich
but yeah man like so at the end of the
day like
what what difference does it make if
we've got Grays when we make our first
movie yeah I think of anything it's a
better movie to be made because we've
had 40 years well however old you are
that amount of time
uh to to to learn how to tell a [ __ ]
story
yeah man I I had this thought the other
day I'm like you know you the oddworth
filmmaker fallacy almost of like you
know you have this like this top tier of
directors who make their one movie and
that's what yeah you know propels the
whole career I think that's completely
like the worst thing to hold up yeah as
a young filmmaker as what you need to be
because
look there's a lot of factors that went
into this and like a lot of them are
just straight up Geniuses but like to a
point where it's like like detrimental
almost to like I feel like probably
other parts of their lives like if
you're gonna have a balance you need to
learn by just doing and like do it over
and over and over and over and over and
then do it it's like how
I'm not I've come to accept that I'm not
that filmmaker who like will make the
first movie and like win the best
picture and then or you know like dude
neither am I yeah
I'm okay with it yes and I'm okay it's
very freeing to realize that and just
let yourself yeah fail and and also
succeed and then just like be like okay
on to the next one let's do it and do
the home I can get on a tirade the whole
genius thing
it's like okay
so like you plop out of your mom on the
delivery room floor and you stand up
Suddenly and you're like get me a 35
millimeter you know what I mean no no I
mean I think some people are generally
curious about certain things and then
they're they're brought up in an
environment that Fosters that Curiosity
and that allows them to at an early age
really sort of discover
talent and I think that sometimes that
happens when you're if you're very
fortunate it happens when you're younger
but sometimes that happens when you're
50 years old and you've had some sort of
life experience and you're like
I've learned how to to finally
communicate yeah yeah there's a lot of
pressure I think we put on ourselves to
have all the right answers especially
when you're directing and like it's not
about I don't really think it's about
having the right answer it's trusting
the people around you to to not tell
someone what to do but to talk about
what to do and you have to be really
vulnerable with yourself to be able to
do that right to like look at someone in
the eye and they go okay so how do you
think I should do this and the right
answer isn't to tell them what to do
it's to ask them how they feel and then
negotiate that and you you have to be
okay with like not having the answer
that's like easy yeah you know you know
what to to jump in yeah I found a trick
for that too oftentimes I know the
answer and when I'm there I ask them
anyways yeah and what it does is it
helps you practice that but also it it
tests your theory you know what you
sound like I'm gonna throw it back and
you sound like an editor
because that's what you do with editing
you know not that you know the right cut
but when you're working for the client
yeah you ask them because you you know
what's gonna happen and then sometimes
you are wrong you know and it does test
your theory but dude but it's it's so
refreshing because it isn't about being
right or wrong it's just about being
inspired yeah and so I'd rather have all
the people working for me inspired than
following my orders yeah yeah no one
wants a real Sergeant this is this has
been a great podcast I feel like if
we're coming to the end here like man
this is just in some ways this has been
therapeutic because I know Joe and I've
been talking just with like the short
we're working on it's like you just
gotta keep grinding it out and stuff and
just believing like yeah yeah and just
keep doing it can I ask about that like
are you guys at Liberty to talk about
this short film that I've been hearing
so much about here uh I think so yeah
okay
um and I was gonna ask like after you
kind of explain it I'd love to know like
what your guys's like goals are for this
is this an exclusive right now yeah we
dropped we've dropped Little Seeds
um and people know that we are working
on it
um you know our process on it and I'm
sure Fenner has his perspective and the
reason I I'm working with Fenner and the
reason why I love this man so much is
that
um to what you said earlier he he's way
smarter than I am and he can do
something I can't do he looks smarter
yeah so
um so our process has been really cool
developing this and the reason we're
making it
um I guess to answer that first is
um that we feel like this property
um has so much to offer and you know
there have been versions of it that have
been made
um but it's a property that is like
really iconic and people know and uh it
is a horror it's funny that we're all
talking about horror stuff it is horror
um and taking something that people know
um it's kind of what people do is start
or what they're doing with Star Wars
taking this like iconic property and
telling a small story yeah
um so it gets people in the nose oh it's
Halo I I don't I don't know Halo Halo
Thunder loves Halo yeah but my idea with
this and the reason I think it's a
project that I found interesting is that
the story that we're telling isn't a
bunch of guys going shooting people and
you know it's not a video game it's it's
three people three people
um and I think it's a story worth
telling it's it's about Humanity it's
about
um what what you'll do uh for a cause
that you believe in it's a very Bleak
story and it's a story that resonated
with me right now because
we all want to be doing something to
help
um and the truth of the fact is the
matter is that we might not be doing the
right thing even with the best intention
and that's what this story is and it's
actually a really hard thing to talk
about because
I think most people are good I really do
but we get blindsided by the means to an
end and that's what the story is about
and it just so happens to be in Halo
um all framed wrapped up by Halo yeah
that was our thought processes use and
already established IP like similar to
The Punisher thing
um
to have the framework for the universe
for the built-in audience
um and then essentially use it as a
jumping off point to be like hey we did
this thing and it may be a case of where
we get you know
I don't know what would be Papa Master
Chief comes down and says we can't
release the film but but then we'll just
do it yeah yeah exactly it's a learning
it's a learn process I think that was
our that was our ultimate goal to learn
how to do it and it's been hugely
inspiring just like knowing that you've
made your film and so doing something
that's like 10 minutes 15 minutes is and
it's it's been a really unique process
like unlike any other project because in
when I was in Boston and God bless
vagrants and those guys because they
were the first people who gave me work
this who we know each other through I
was directing things
um and I was even younger than I am now
obviously and I was really trying to
figure out what process would work for
me and this project has been one that
because there's no timeline I've really
taken the time to work on
not the end goal but the process to get
there and that's literally the name of
your podcast
um so it's like you know and what and
I'm finding new ways to do it because
we've pre-visualized the entire thing
shot on iPhone and now we're going
through the next step of previous
pre-visualizing CG in it and so taking
really baby steps yeah but making sure
it's like I've always buttoned up put
pressure on myself to finish something
really fast
um because of the world that I can't
like adds you want to finish it really
fast everyone wants it really fast um
and that's what I was doing before and
so everyone wants a 30 second commercial
everyone wants to be tight perfect
Crewcuts yeah yeah and so I love going
baby steps because there's no reason
there's no reason to put that pressure
on yourself when there is no deadline
yeah and so yeah it's been really I was
super inspired by uh the Pixar um book
that I read that uh imagination Inc um
and their process of making movies and
they previous everything to an insane
degree it's really cool to put a button
on that too is all of those small little
baby steps we've been taking now it's
like
oh it's all coming together so quick
yeah at the end yeah yeah so because
it's all there we should show you guys
some stuff afterwards yeah what
so
at the end of the day
what are you guys ultimately want from
this piece
I think for myself
it's just to be just to have done it
okay that's it it doesn't have to it
doesn't have to do anything it could be
something where it never comes out but
just to know that we've done it that's
that's ultimately it for me yeah I think
the people that we've met doing it
because we've kind of brought more
people into the fold on it
um yeah I can't say all the people that
we have but like the people that I've
been able to meet working on it that are
included you know
um and learning to trust myself more
um like to fail in that process
um has been really cool and I think you
know you you all everyone has a dream of
it being seen and we're in a place where
you know it it will get seen more than
if I just like post it on my Instagram
oh for sure so I think
I'll say this the goal I want what I
want out of it is I want to hear
what Strangers think about it
um not that I need like validation but
like
I
am so
inspired by the fact that like what I
make can impact someone it's something
that I've learned from the show that I
make here that like making something
that is
what we make is funny usually and I
don't really want to make something
funny and I want to hear how people are
affected by it yeah that's my goal to
see if my crazy little idea someone in
the comment section goes wow it is
really crazy that even though that
person made the right decision in the
moment ultimately it was actually a
detriment and I think that that reminds
me of this in my life that would be like
the victory I'd be like yep okay the
metaphor worked you know because that's
what I'm always worried about as the
editor I don't want that man I'm gonna
want people to watch your stuff and
respond to it it sounds like you guys
got good reason and like good a good
reason to do it
um and then if you're looking
and the larger picture
the stuff that you guys are the tech the
techniques the previous
the planning all those things if you go
through that process you're making
yourself valuable
for you know like a like a Star Wars
show yeah you know because you're then
proving that you have the skills to do
that and I think
having the skills isn't necessarily
going to get you hired I think if the
emotion is there and if you're telling
that story then this is a great real
piece for you and it's a it's a great
piece for you to be able to say we did
this and you guys have a [ __ ] killer
audience here so you'll have numbers on
that
I had the guy who did the fan film The
Uncharted fan film oh it's amazing on
the show it's incredible yeah he was on
the show that is such yeah amazing I
need to listen to that episode yeah um
he's an interesting cat and he was
talking about
how
obviously it's a property it's a fan
film he didn't get hired to make the new
Uncharted movie for it but what he did
get was because there was so much
interest in it at the Comic-Con they had
him come out to Comic-Con they did this
whole process of Comic-Con and then he
had uh interest from other producers to
make something else Yeah Yeah from it so
I'm just proving you can do it it is so
freaking important yeah um just saying
like yeah just being able to look at
someone be like they can you know push
past all the hurdles and actually finish
something which is hard to just finish
something in the first place that's the
biggest thing is not just proving it to
other people proving it to myself I
think totally yeah and there's never
been a better time to make a fan film I
mean Corridor almost started with like
yeah
that Minecraft Frozen Crossing and then
Minecraft which propelled Corridor
itself out yeah but like I just watched
a great fan film yesterday and or uh it
was great yeah
um yeah you know we're in like a
Renaissance of fan films and they all
have huge [ __ ] budgets oh I see what
you're saying I thought someone else oh
my God man
like being able to take an existing IP
and inject Humanity new Humanity into it
and A New Perspective is like that's
almost the skill you need like forget
about writing an original screenplay I'm
sorry they're not getting made anymore I
know it's like depressing how can I
inject my my yeah it is
man because it's like I hear you in your
perspective of saying you need your own
IP you need your own IP but there is no
perfect formula I think that that's the
most important thing obviously like not
a hot take but it's it's not about the
formula at the end of the day you know
it's about proving it to yourself and
you can prove it to yourself in a
million ways yeah and dude at the end of
the day like
you know while you're waiting around to
create your own IP make this [ __ ]
thing like you just continue to make
things
um because it you know you're always
known by what what you're doing now and
what you're doing lately and it doesn't
matter
how good your last thing was people are
like well yeah but what are you doing
right now yeah yeah well dude thank you
so much I I want to plug your podcast uh
where can we find it like what's the
last thing what what if no one has seen
your podcast which episode do they need
to watch right now and where oh while
you listen to it oh yes because we're
not videotaping it
um
where the [ __ ] okay so I would say we
have great episodes like if you're a big
fan of uh Mandy the Nicholas Cage movie
I have Brett Bachmann on the show who's
the editor for that we actually dig deep
into some of the shots that are iconic
and Mandy and sort of dissect them which
is fun
um I've had Wade Eastwood on the show
who's Tom Cruise's stunt coordinator and
we've talked about
uh the realities behind the Mission
Impossible movies actually what was
those juicy which it was the one with uh
Cavill and I had that bathroom fight
song yeah yeah he walks me through uh
how he came up with that bathroom fight
scene going through that
um so there's a lot of fun stuff as far
as like big names so if you're like
enthralled by like Hot Topic names we
have some of that but most of the show
is um just very personal it's a place
that you can go to when you're feeling
insecure it's kind of like what we just
did here it's a place that you can go to
when you're doubting yourself and uh it
won't just be this guy telling you what
to do
um I actually turn to people for myself
on the show and so I always say at the
beginning of the episode like come on in
grab a beer have a seat on the couch Our
Guest is on the way let's hang out let's
learn something together
um and uh you can listen to it on
Spotify you can listen to it on Apple
podcast go to in love with the
process.com the show is called and level
the process and uh listen to it I like
it yeah it's it's addicting and it is it
really does feel like you're you're in
the room just chilling and hang out with
people in the industry and it honestly
can help
bridge that like you talked about your
process of pitching just getting through
those nerves like the way that you can
just have the confidence building
experience of hearing people talk about
these things is super great I gotta I I
reached out to
um Eddie Hamilton who's the editor of
Mission Impossible and uh yeah I got to
connect you guys because yeah yeah he I
don't have a podcast I just call them we
talked for like three hours one time
yeah and he is a fascinating guy to talk
to and he just did um uh the new Tom
Cruise movie he just did Top Gun so you
would he has so much to say about the
process of that but anyway man thank you
so much thank you for making therapy
yeah this has been a lot it was awesome
you guys thank you so much and on our
podcast now we crack the beer now yeah
oh yeah
thank you so much man thank you guys
seriously thank you guys for watching go
check out Mike's stuff yeah